hey everybody and welcome to a very
small mini series in which I'll be
building a reindeer reserve in Planet
Zoo but I would be it mm-hmm I won't be
doing it alone I've got my dear friend
Wix here I Wix hello are you doing I am
doing yeah doing all right how about
yourself I'm doing a quite okay
giving given the circumstances yeah
but yes opposed idli we were gonna
record this but I think almost more than
three months ago actually that was the
original plan right yeah sort of sort of
yeah when the DLC kind of dropped right
yeah exactly because this is like
completely the wrong theme because I
think by the time this video comes out
tomorrow the the new South American tank
will come out but we started this little
side project as a way to explore the
pieces from the Arctic pack so yeah this
is definitely a little bit late yeah it
is serious but will it's okay
I mean yeah but better that it comes out
and it just doesn't see daylight yeah
exactly
now the funny thing is that we were
originally planning to record this in a
way that I've never done it before and I
think you've never done it before either
as in we wanted to like physically
record together because we were gonna be
in the same space on New Year's Eve when
we were actually celebrating yeah New
Year's Eve together which was super cool
it was but yeah that didn't end up
happening and then all of a sudden here
we are three months later and there's a
new DLC and we're kind of like alright
if we don't put this thing out right now
and then it's gonna be way too outdated
and people are just gonna laugh at us so
yeah mm-hmm getting this out at some
horrible timing but yeah the idea was
basically to explore the Arctic pieces
and at the time which was over three
months ago I think we we found the
reindeer a really cool animal to work
with because everybody was building like
polar bear habitats
all kinds of cool things and I feel like
the reindeer never got the love that it
deserved yeah that's that's true and
actually we did actually have some sort
of a concept but then our good friend
you ever came right out of there oh yeah
it's true and took our our little
concept yes damn which were awesome by
the way yeah that was so cool actually
I'll link that in the description
because that was such a cool build like
for the longest time we were thinking of
building some sort of Viking thing with
a polar bear habitat and including some
sort of shipwreck viewing platform with
all kinds of crazy ideas that we were
brainstorming and I think just the day
after we sort of came up with those
ideas
Yoda just posted the most ridiculous
build ever just a completely custom
Viking ship yes so cool so yeah yeah we
had to come up with something else
eventually which ended up being the
reindeer habitat and specifically for
the theme I think this was kind of
coming more from my side at the time I
just always wanted to try a Russian sort
of architecture so that's how this
little building here started out
specifically there's a thing called a
Dutch a Dutch I think that's how you
pronounce it anyway it's a Russian kind
of summer house that a lot of Russian
people have and used to have in Soviet
Union times which I think it's quite
culturally relevant because many people
lived in the city lived in small
apartment blocks that were very similar
and strictly regulated but you could
have like a summer house summer in
nature where you could go for for your
holidays and this inspired a whole sort
of own architecture style and I thought
this was a really cool kind of
architecture I think we both actually
came yeah we both actually found this
from a booklet that included Russian
architecture and included a bunch of
this Dutch architecture
I just forgot the name of it yeah I
remember
yeah maybe
maybe I can find it here yeah but
there's this in any case like this this
booklet with some really really cool
drawings of Russian architecture that I
think we're never really realized but it
it was a huge inspiration actually for
my Morrow's coaster and planet coaster
back in the day and I think it's just
such a cool sort of sugar coated wooden
but super detailed kind of architecture
with lots of really cool ornaments and
just so much like the things you can do
with the wooden detailing that it's
something really fun to build in this
game so I just really wanted to give
that a try and that's where this kind of
build came from so this is going to be
the main shelter inside the habitat
which is kind of against what I usually
like to do because I'm more of a fan of
making natural shelters for animals just
kind of more of their natural
environment I guess but given that these
are reindeer I just thought it would be
really cool matically to give them some
sort of almost Christmas Eve vibe
Russian traditional architecture with a
lot of woodwork and detailing and yeah I
think this this Architecture from this
booklet it was just the right thing for
it god I'm so mad I forgot the name of
it did you find any pictures of it no no
I'm trying to scroll here finding some
stuff oh well but yeah it definitely
also helped me when I had to build
something out of this here yeah it's
such a cool thing if I do end up finding
it I'm definitely gonna link it
somewhere but I think the way that I
went about this and I think the way that
you're doing it is well it's just saving
some of the coolest pictures from this
booklet and putting them somewhere on
your computer and not actually saving
any references or anything so I always
lose where I actually got the pictures
from yeah I kind of have like an
inspiration folder that is just like
everything yeah yeah safer
me which I also think is like something
really important to have for me the
question of like what inspires you and
keeps you going
comes up so much and I think something
that just works more than anything is
just keeping a folder where you know
everything that you come across that
inspires you you just save it in there
or if you want to start a new theme and
you're not sure how to tackle it just
look up a bunch of references and save
it in there and you always have
something like a crutch to fall back on
and get inspiration from that's kind of
like how I've done it the last few few
years I've been playing these games
mm-hmm yeah the same and it's really fun
as well yeah yeah I also have this issue
like sometimes when sometimes I need
kind of like some sort of reference
picture just to get started to get the
kickstart sort of like like the base of
the building the structure and stuff
yeah it really helps sometimes you don't
have to like go and build what exactly
this picture shows you just kind of like
helps you get going yeah exactly
which is also something I did in my
video when I try to build something is
about building here ya know that's
always the way that it kind of works for
me as well just something to fall back
on I mean nobody comes up with ideas
completely on their own even in real
life architects always take the
inspiration from somewhere and you know
that's that's just kind of the the cool
thing about creative processes in
general is that you always take things
that you've seen and just kind of blend
them together in your head maybe add a
few things and this whole new thing
comes out yeah I totally agree I was
getting me this roof here yeah I was
getting kind of annoyed at this point
because it's such a hassle every time to
build these shingle roofs but I think
it's worth it
oh it looks amazing just spot-on Thank
You Man
yeah it's I'm so glad actually that this
African piece is included in the game
the one with all of the logs that you
see because the thing that you so often
find on
he's Russian but also other kinds of
Nordic architecture is these these walls
made out of logs where it's just a bunch
of wooden logs on top of each other that
form the wall and it kind of looks like
this building looks as though all of
these logs are just separate individual
pieces but I'm so glad that there's this
African piece where you can just stack a
few of them on top of each other and you
don't have to like put endless logs on
top of each other because otherwise I'm
pretty sure you know with the shingle
roof also this building would have
exceeded the maximum amount of pieces
for a blueprint and probably also start
lagging a lot yeah I think you told me
actually when I got into the sort of
shoe that I have just there's these sort
of lock things the and the Africa there
and the Africa theme that I could use
and you're right they're really helpful
yeah really helpful yeah I know that
those things are definitely the life
savers of this entire build especially
because and this is just something that
keeps happening to me and planets ooh
whenever you build too many items too
close to each other and I guess it's
something to do with the calculation of
where animals can travel but the
buildings it becomes really laggy like
it's it would take seconds the place of
one new piece or something like that I
don't know if you had that as well oh I
had it especially in the actually in the
bagans beta I mean I have that a lot
yeah also with its arraign and stuff
yeah yeah yeah this game just gets so
confused if you put too many pieces too
close to each other yeah it's not happy
it's not happy for that
you know I mean I I remember because I
was went in here and after you and I
also built a custom roof and and and
stuff and I immediately just like this
sort of yeah I just lost so many frames
already this moment I was kind of yeah
yeah for context by the way we're
recording this so late that at the point
that we are recording this commentary we
also already finished
well weeks already finished the
time-lapse for the second episode as
well so
we're really gonna have to like storm
through this thing and actually finish
it sometime soon yeah
which on the bright side at least we'll
be able to put these episodes out pretty
quickly like once this episode is out
the next one can come maybe I don't know
a few days later or so there maybe in
the next day I don't know we'll see yeah
exactly although I also have to be
honest I kind of feel like personally
once the South American pack comes out I
do want to play with that a bit more I
thought it's gonna be a bit dangerous to
have this sort of like arctic old build
laying around which almost feels a bit
outdated as soon as that DLC comes out
but we really have to get back into it
and try to finish it yeah I mean we do
have like a like I wanna make like a
little extra thing after that I did you
know in adding some shops and then I
think you want to do some more with the
habitat and stuff yeah yeah so yes it's
a short series as you said it's nothing
nothing super crazy yeah I guess we
haven't really explained it too much but
the idea is really just to stick to one
habitat and just make one like really
detailed habitat with a small area
around it and some shops or restaurants
or kind of things like this like one
complete little themed area inside a
fictional zoo and that'll just be the
project in general yeah pretty much
which yeah I think for me is kind of
good also because my computer just
doesn't handle large projects at least I
know for koalas ooh it's just it's
already breaking down and I might like
15fps so I think for the time being as
long as I have this computer I'm really
just gonna try to stick also to these
smaller habitats focus builds yeah then
you can also maybe and I get more into
it yeah like focus more on one yeah it's
at or or two maybe
yeah that's true yeah because this one
is gonna be quite detailed it is it is
yeah me I was just about to say that
building you did is absolutely stunning
oh thank you yeah it's basically the
focus of this first episode like aside
from this building I'll just be building
the general surroundings and it starts
for the the viewing platforms of the
actual habitat but this building is
really kind of the focus of this episode
and my goal for the rest of it is to
just build a landscape around it to put
it in the right context and see what it
looks like eventually it's supposed to
kind of resemble yeah the general look
of a stable building which is why I kind
of feel like four reindeers
you know they're not as wild of an
animal as that some things are and I
guess are they tameable actually I don't
know to what extent they are me neither
actually it's interesting I actually
should have looked much more into that
probably before this but no I just feel
like for them it fits and it just
creates this this cool scene if you're
looking from the perspective of the
guests I am I'm actually gonna look that
up can they be tamed I don't know I mean
the the Santa Claus has reindeer yeah
they are so much investigated apparently
oh I guess my instinct was right there
yeah I just kind of assumed that but I
don't know if they're really used for
anything per se
I'm just looking through that yeah I'm
just looking through the Wikipedia at
this point but at least there are a lot
of them still in the world so that's
good although they are full notable but
then is a pretty much every animal at
this point because some of the animals
in planets do like honestly this game
taught me a lot about animals because
before it came out like I would go to
zoo sometimes but I wasn't you know an
animal expert in any way but now every
time I started habitat for
animal and I read through the entire you
know all of the info on the zoo pedia in
the game to know you know what I need to
provide for them I'm slowly becoming
more of an animal expert well I mean
that is good I mean it is good when you
can do that and then there's some pretty
cool habitats I mean I I'm like more
yeah I mean I don't go into so much like
I mean I built a habitat for them but
that's I think that's basically dead I
don't research so much I just like the
building aspect to be honest yeah right
yeah that's fair enough
it's also i guess the kind of thing
where everybody has their own sort of
favorite Anish as well to do and i don't
know for me
you're kind of Nicias really like
building shops and restaurants and all
of these kinds of like really lively
buildings and stuff yeah I like that
which is also funny because I'm Mike I'm
also a lot into architecture but like
the total opposite my buildings are
usually way too dead and not actually
functional so and then in that sense I
think we actually cover each other kind
of well which is also pretty important
usually in a collab at this point I'm
just sort of adding the foliage by the
way I'm not entirely sure how happy I am
keeping it this open because I'm really
considering whether it should be more
forested because I'm not gonna put much
more trees than this in but yeah I like
it so far I might play a bit more with
that later I kind of like it a little
bit more open might you have it here
yeah yeah I also have to give a shout
out to Pond shrimp who has a really cool
YouTube channel as well it's just kind
of underrated I don't think I've
actually ever talked about Pond shrimp
in one of my videos but now that they
make some really cool videos so I'm just
gonna link that down and I got really
inspired by the rockwork because I saw
palm swim do this kind of trick where
you put a bunch of very small rocks to
go together especially around the edges
the lake or underneath the water surface
which I think was a really cool way to
do it normally I just kind of stick to
the very large Brooks but putting a
bunch of these really small ones
actually looks really cool as well so
that it sounds actually yeah that's what
kind of this rock work was inspired by
which in general Pond shrimp is just so
good at foliage in in that sense I feel
like that kind of like Mike who is just
also way too good at foliage and I wish
I could one day become as good at it as
they are
it just takes ya so much knowledge like
it really does yeah I think I think my
extent of foliage is really just putting
a bunch of trees and shrubs together as
I see fit until it just kind of starts
looking good and meanwhile they're
always like oh and this is this exact
tree and it has this in this name and it
needs this amount of sunlight and it
works well in this kind of context it's
it's absolutely insane I mean it's good
to know those kind of people oh yeah
that is true
yep well I'm also like you there I'm
like oh this tree oh this tree looks
good here what if I place one more oh
this also look good I mean it's just I'm
not really I mean of course if I'm
building something like I don't put like
a desert plant or something next to a
fantasy or you know like that I can but
if there's leaves on the tree yeah same
sometimes I even like go outside the
biome or the continent if it just looks
good although I also have to say I know
that Mike also does that a lot like very
often if you start pulling apart his
foliage it's it's also still more about
you know making it look good than making
it completely realistic which i think is
also fair enough I think you should also
do it like that to some extent because
if you just let yourself be limited by
the foliage you know that the game
itself has for certain themes or certain
like countries you end up with very
limited amount of foliage I think yeah
oh yeah for sure
and you don't have a lot of choices to
go with yeah speaking of which I I think
I do want to experiment more with this
general sort of path thing because I
just kind of put this here because I
figured the only choice I had for this
was just to put down a straight concrete
wall but especially with the thing that
you build in the next episode which I'm
not going to spoil anything about but
looking at what that's going to look
like I think this wall looks just
horrendous and yeah yeah
one experiment is a bit more with that
alright thank you appreciate it
well I mean I know you're gonna do more
stuff on it that's more what I mean yeah
yeah I'm just not sure yet what's but it
it's definitely it's definitely a
placeholder that all never get fixed at
some point maybe actually once we get
the new pieces in the South American
tank there might be some useful stuff in
that I'm not sure but I bet there will
be and maybe something even more clutter
yeah exactly and just some general rock
work and foliage and things like that
even if it's a South American pack that
should hopefully be some stuff that can
work in different themes oh for sure for
sure
always foliage is just nice yep although
I'm mostly looking forward to the new
glass pieces those are just gonna be so
cool oh yeah that's right we get those I
forgot that yeah you can do a lot with
those because they're finally you know
they don't have anything around the
glass so you can do pretty much you know
it shaped them in whatever way you can
so that's gonna be super cool yeah
remember when we got that in Plain Cole
oh yeah that was a game-changer yeah
it's also I mean it kind of weird to me
that they have all this glass in the
game and why didn't they just end it
first of all right yeah doesn't make
sense to me and I was questioning this
back then as well because I mean
obviously we can't look into what
they're doing and you know what they
have to work with but for the longest
time they were saying that they couldn't
add separate glass pieces because it
would lag the game or you know just not
work with the engine but when they added
it it was working fine and before that
there were few similar glass pieces as
well which were just not you know off
the grid and we're in separate glass
pieces but I'm glad that I figured it
out much quicker with planet zoom I
guess because those things are just so
flexible mm-hmm yeah they they really
really save it save it sometime yeah
specially if it's off grid so yeah
exactly making a backstage building here
yeah kind of this is a sort of the the
hold in the holding area for the animals
so where they could get treated or where
where they could make the food etc or
the actual shelter where they're gonna
stay outside the view of the guests and
I know it looks ugly like really boxy
and straight but I want to hide this
building away as much as possible and
just kind of have it blend in with the
general area so there will also be some
trees around it and some small trees on
top of it as well and that green roof to
sort of look the view of this shelter in
general and just you know not make it
pop out as much as possible and once a
few trees are placed in front of it I
think from the perspective of the path
at least you really have to pay very
close attention to notice it in the
distance so that should hopefully you
know make for an actual shelter which is
kind of unnoticeable and instead
hopefully the the people's attention
will go to the the shelter building
which is like detailed and stuff so yeah
you can see all that detailed and stuff
yeah because the other one is literally
just a bunch of concrete walls
and stuff I was also kind of getting
tired at this point I was just like
alright let's get it over with
okay fair yeah but also nevertheless
everything you don't you thank you man
at speaking of getting it over with
that's gonna be it for this episode so
yeah I'd like to thank you weeks for
coming over
and hosting this commentary with me yeah
Thank You Man it's awesome yeah no
problem and thank you everybody in the
audience viewing this video and for the
next video we're gonna head over to
wix's channel and yeah well let's see
you guys in the next one bye bye bye
[Music]
you
[Music]